so you might want to Pokemon Shield your
eyes because scarlet and violet spoilers
have already begun to leak online two
weeks ahead of release a copy of the
game has worked its way into the hands
of a leaker with several posts from that
person appearing on the Pokemon scarlet
and violet subreddit the posts show off
a couple new monsters alongside the
evolutionary forms for starter Pokemon
foikoko and Olive Pokemon smallif so if
you're sensitive to that type of
spoilers you might want to start muting
some keywords on social media and this
isn't the first time that a Mainline
entry in the Pokemon series has leaked
information out early either in one
Infamous case two Pokemon sword and
shield leakers ended up having to pay
three hundred thousand dollars in
Damages to Nintendo after the pair were
accused of stealing trade secrets from
the company by taking photos of an
unreleased strategy guide for the games
when it comes to new Pokemon that
haven't leaked gimme ghoul was released
over the weekend in the official Pokemon
Twitter account has announced a new
trailer for Pokemon scarlet and violet
it will Air tomorrow November 8th at 6
a.m Pacific 9 A.M Eastern but let's say
you've seen enough Pokemon trailers and
you want something new to get excited
about well you should pay attention to
the day after on Wednesday November 9th
I say this because there's a Nintendo
Indie World Showcase schedule to take
place on that day at 9 A.M Pacific 12
p.m Eastern and it will run for about 25
minutes there have been no specific
games mentioned but for comparison's
sake the last Indie World featured games
like ooblets slit and gumbrella a game
that I recently played a demo of on
Steam deck and I can't wait for the full
release another game that I'm waiting
for is Final Fantasy 16 a game that
you'll need a PlayStation 5 for if
you're not willing to be patient we've
already known for some time that the
game would be an exclusive but now a new
PlayStation commercial has confirmed at
around the 14 second Mark that Final
Fantasy 6 team will be a PlayStation 5
exclusive for only 6 months this time
frame pales in comparison to another up
upcoming Square Enix release for spoken
which launches January 24th and will be
a PlayStation console exclusive for two
years so when Final Fantasy 16 drops and
the fomo is starting to take hold just
remind yourself that in six months from
that release date you might be able to
buy it on something like Steam and
speaking of valve storefront Ubisoft
games might be coming back following
several years of being off of it a
GitHub user by the name of ubre
discovered that the source code for the
Assassin's Creed Valhalla Ubisoft
connect page has been recently updated
and now contains the word steam
specifically it reads internal Dev QC
Assassin's Creed Valhalla steam in a
statement to inside gamer Ubisoft said
quote we don't comment on rumors and
speculation if ubisoft's games are
returning to valve's platform it would
be a big deal considering that Ubisoft
has been favoring releasing its games on
PC through the epic game store as well
as its own launcher ubisoft's last theme
released was trials Rising back on
February 26 2019 interestingly the
upcoming Assassin's Creed Mirage is
listed as a PC release but it only has
an epic game store Page and not a steam
one however it's possible that Ubisoft
is continuing its relationship with epic
games as well as Steam now hit the
comment section let me know what your
name would be if you were a Pokemon but
get creative it can't be one of the
Pokemon that already exists I'll see you
tomorrow
foreign
foreign